A key idea to many behavioral therapies is the use of reinforcement to shape
and change behavior. However, other techniques are used, such as extinction,
and this was used in the study I just talked about with the psychiatric nurse
as a behavioral engineer. They used extinction to decrease symptoms of
schizophrenia, but let's look at a different type of therapy that uses
reinforcement. One successful ABA technique that is used by behavioral
therapists, is a token economy. And here desired behaviors are reinforced with
a token. That could be something like a sticker, a star on the board or some
type of chip. These tokens are accumulated, and can later be exchanged for
other items or privileges. For example, a child with ADHD may be put on a token
economy. Wherein he gets a token for every homework assignment that he
completes on time. After he accumulates 5 stars, he gets 10 extra minutes of
recess. Moreover, if he earns 10 stars he gets to go on the field trip with the
class. The token economy technique has been found to be especially effective in
treating drug addiction. So, let's look at example of that. Steven Higgins and
his colleagues conducted a series of studies, where they gave cocaine dependent
participants tokens for each drug free urine sample that they provided. In some
of the studies, the value of the tokens increased for each consecutive drug
free sample. So for example, perhaps the first token was worth $0.25, if they
provided a drug free urine on the next day it would be increased to $0.50. On
the third day if they provided a drug free sample it would go to $0.75. Now
remember these were just tokens, they didn't earn actual money, and part of
this was because they wanted to make sure that the tokens could be exchanged
for appropriate items. Meaning they didn't want to give these individuals money
and perhaps risk them taking that money and going out and buying drugs. So
again, if drugs were found in the urine, the value of the token decreased to
the original starting value. So again if they had consecutive drug free urines,
the token value increased each time. But if drugs were found in the urine, it
went back to the original starting value. In these studies the researchers
found a significant decrease in drug using. Especially compared to other
therapies such as narcotics anonimous. These individuals spent longer time
drug-free, than individuals in those other treatments. Given the success of
these types of studies, this behavioral approach has been listed by the
National Institute of Drug Abuse as the best option for drug addiction, along
with medication.